حذر المبعوث الاممي الى اليمن من انزلاق
هذا البلد بعيدا عن السلام ما لم يتم
اسكات البنادق وخلال جلسه لمجلس الامن قال
مارتن جريفث ان انهيار الوضع الميداني
يهدد بتقويض العمليه السياسيه مشيرا الى
انه ارسل مسوده لاتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار
الى الطرفين المتحاربين في اليمن الاسبوع
الماضي
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا كان هذا خبر حلقتنا
ونناقش ما وراء هذا الخبر كيف يقرا
الحوثيون والحكومه اليمنيه تحذير المبعوث
الاممي بالتزامن مع محادثاتهم المرتقبه في
جنيف بشان الافراج عن
الاسرى وهل تؤشر التحركات والاتصالات
الامميه والروسيه والسعوديه بشان الازمه
اليمنيه الى امكانيه انطلاق مسار جديد
للسلام في
اليمن
يصف المبعوث الاممي مارتن جريفث الوضع في
اليمن بالسيء ويقول ان مناشدته للاطراف في
هذا البلد بسيطه للغايه مفادها ان يختاروا
السلام وينهوا الصراع ويعمل مع الامم
المتحده بشكل عاجل من اجل التسويه مشيرا
الى ان المجتمع المدني في اليمن ينخرط في
دور محوري في الضغوط للوصول الى حل سلمي
واعرب المبعوث الاممي الى اليمن عن قلقه
اذاء اغلاق مطار صنعاء امام الرحلات
الانسانيه مشيرا الى مساع لبدء محادثات
هذا الاسبوع في جنيف بين الحكومه اليمنيه
والحوثيين بشان الافراج عن الاسرى وعلمت
الجزيره ان وفدي الجانبين قد توجها بالفعل
من عدن وصنعاء الى
جنيف يقلقني اعلان اقفال مطار صنعاء امام
الرحلات الانسانيه وهذا يؤثر على عمليات
الامم المتحده ووكالات الاغاثه في اليمن
في توفير المساعدات الانسانيه التي تمنع
الان من الوصول الى صنعاء اذا سمحت
الترتيبات اللوجستيه بذلك وهي الان باتت
اكثر تعقيدا بسبب جائحه فيروس كورونا
نتوقع رؤيه الاطراف هذا الاسبوع في سويسرا
يتابعون نقاشاتهم بشان تنفيذ اتفاق تبادل
السجناء برعايه مشتركه بين مكتبي واللجنه
الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر ولمناقشة
الانترنت عبد الحميد صيام الخبير في شؤون
الامم المتحده وابدا بضيفي من نيويورك
دكتور عبد الحميد
صيام تصريحات مارتن جريفث في الواقع هل هي
النداء الاخير لانقاذ اليمن من الانزلاق
الى ما حذر منه وهو مسار الحرب وهل يصحب
هذا النداء الاخير عواقب يعني هل هذا هو
النداء الاخير والا ام ليس هنالك
الا يعني هو نداء مهم وصرخه في اللحظات
الاخيره قبل الانهيار الكبير وقد وضع
المسؤوليه على الطرفين وقال امامكم الان
خيار اما ان تختاروا انقاذ اليمن او ان
تنزلك اكثر الى الكارثه وقد وضح بشكل مسهب
كل التفاصيل التي تدعو الى الى التشاؤم
سواء من حيث
اي الاشتعال المعارك في منطقه مارب تحديد
انتشار فروس كورونا بشكل غير قادرين على
ضبطه المساعدات الانسانيه تكاد تتوقف خاصه
وان الدول المانحه لم تقدم ما وعدت به ولم
يصل الا حوالي 30%
اغلاق مطار صنعاء هذه قضيه اخرى التهديد
بانفجار ناقله صافر كل هذه مجتمعه
كلها تؤدي الى مثل هذا الوضع الاسود في
اليمن وبالتالي هو وجه هذا النداء لا اريد
ان اسميه الاخير لكنه نداء فعلا صادر من
من من حاله الياس لعل الاطراف لعل الاطراف
يستمعون اليه هل هل هذا التحذير له انياب
هل هذا التحذير هل هنالك والا سيحدث كذا
ام يعني نداء اليائس
فقط ليس امام الامم المتحده قدره على فرض
ما تريد اجندتها او توقف الاطراف عن
انزلاق الى
الهاويه بدون ان يكون هناك لمجلس الامن
دور في ذلك واعطاء الامم المتحده القوه
التي تريدها
والاحتياجات التي تلزمها في مثل هذه
الحالات مجلس الامني يوجه نداءات ياخذ قرا
وما معنى اذا ان يقول نحن نراقب تصرفات
الجانبين يعني ما فائده هذه المراقبه اذا
لم تكن هنالك
عواقب لعلها رساله ايضا تذهب الى الدول
التي تدعم هذه الاطراف فهناك مثلا
صحيح الاشتباك تقريبا اساسا بين اليمنيين
لكن هناك
دول الحرب في اليمن لم تعد فقط حربا يمنيه
يمنيه هناك اطراف تدعم هذا الطرف وهناك
دول تدعم هذا الطرف ولذلك ايضا النداء ليس
موجها فقط للحوثيين وحكومه الشرعيه ولكن
ايضا للجهات التي تقف مع هذين الطرفين
وخاصه دوله مثل السعوديه ومثل ايران
ومثل الاتحاد الروسي ومثل دول كثيره يعني
لها دور يعني هي رسائل في اتجاهات شتى من
صنعاء نصر الدين عامر وكيل وزاره الاعلام
التابعه للحوثيين كيف تقراون هذه الرسائل
التي بعث بها مارتن
جريفيث نعم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اولا
نحن نعتقد بان مساله التفاوض بخصوص الاسرى
هو تفاوض في شان انساني ونحن نحرس دائما
على ان يكون هذا الملف انساني بعيدا عن
الجانب السياسي وان كان الجانب السياسي
عليه تاثير او الجانب العسكري لكن نحرس
دائما الا يكون له بعد سياسي او عسكري
وانما يظل في بعده الانساني ولكن اذا نجحت
هذه المفاوضات قد تعطي دفعه وبارك امل
لاستمرار جهود المبعوث الاممي في العمل في
الملف السياسي او المفاوضات السياسيه لكن
في ظل تعثر الملفات الانسانيه مثل ملف
الاسرى واغلاق ايضا مطار صنعاء وعدم ادخال
المشتقات النفطيه هذا لا يبشر بخير وفدكم
ووفد الحكومه الشرعيه وصل بالفعل الى جنيف
لحضور هذه المحادثات لكن امام الحوثيين
وامام الحكومه اليمنيه مسوده مسوده لوقف
اطلاق النار ارسلها المبعوث الاممي قبل
اسبوع هل اطلعتم على هذه المسوده هل كونتم
رايا
بشانها انا بالنسبه لمعلوماتي ان هناك ال
على يعني عمليه التواصل ما بين الوفد
الوطني وما بين حكومه في صنعاء وما بين
مارتن غريفث ليست على ما يرام وليست
طبيعيه اي انه الى الان لم يستطع ان يقدم
شيئا في الملفات الانسانيه كي تكون حافز
للدخول في الملف السياسي او المشاورات
السياسيه انا اعتقد ان المساله ليست بهذه
البساطه وانها مساله ارسال يعني مسوده
اتفاق بهذه السهوله قدمت من صنعاء مسوده
اتفاق قبل فتره وقيل بانها تؤخذ وت ع ويتم
حولها النقاش لكن لهم لم يردوا حولها نحن
نعتقد ان هذا كله ذر الرماد في العيون
وليس هناك اي جديه لاي انخراط في حل
السياسي طالما لم تكن هناك جديه في
الملفات الانسانيه وخاصه ملف الحصار ومنع
المشتقات النفطيه عندما تغلق المستشفيات
لا يمكن ان نتحدث في ملفات سياسيه وملفات
عسكريه طالما والملف الانساني بهذا السوء
وهذه الكارثي هذا الكارثي الوضع الكارثي
والمبعوث امممي وقادر على ان يقدم شي في
هذا سيد محمد خيزان طبعا المبعوث الاممي
انتقد من جانب الحكومه الشرعيه كما انتقد
من جانب الحوثيين لكن فيما يتعلق بمبادرته
لوقف اطلاق النار او مسوله وقف اطلاق
النار التي قال انها وصلت الى الجانبين هل
الحكومه الشرعيه حكومه الرئيس عبد ال
اللهو منصور هذه كونت رايا في هذا الاطار
ام انها تنتظر محادثات جنيف
ايضا مساء الخير اخي الكريم شكرا لك
ولضيوفك الكرام وساده المشاهدين الحكومه
اليمنيه تؤكد على دعم جهود المبعوث
الامومي الخاص الى اليمن السيد مارتين
غريفيث والانخراط الايجابي مع الجهود
المتصله بوقف اطلاق النار والاجراءات
الاقتصاديه والسياسيه لاستئناف العمليه
السياسيه لكن للاسف الشديد بالمقابل جماعه
الحوثي مستمره في التصعيد والتحشيد وقصف
المدن بالصواريخ البالستيه
وال التحشيد ل
يعني للهجوم على مارب والجوف والبيضاء
تصريحات السيد غريفيث بامس والخجوله في
مجلس الامن وانه يحذر وغير متفائل للاسف
الشديد له دور سلبي في ذلك فهو لم يوضح من
الذي يعرقل تنفيذ اتفاق السلام من الذي
يقصف المدنيين بالصواريخ البالستيه
والطائرات المسيره من الذي ينقض الاتفاقات
كلها هي جماعه الحوثي يعني هو الاتهامات
المتبادله كثيره يعني الحوثي ايضا ربما
يقول من الذي يقصف المدن من الذي ي في
صنعاء من الذي
يحاصر يعني الغالبيه العظمى من سكان اليمن
ويلقي بذلك بالتبعيه في ذلك ومسؤوليه في
ذلك على التحالف السعودي الاماراتي لكن
بعيدا عن ذلك هل الحكومه
الشرعيه كونت رايا فيما يتعلق بمساويه وقف
اطلاق النار ام تنتظر ما ستسفر عنه
محادثات
جنيف بالنسبه ل الحكومه اليمنيه كما قلت
هي مع السلام الدائم السلام المرتكز على
على المبادئ
الثلاث
وطق النار هذا بشكل عام
يعني في يتعلق بهذه النقطه تحديدا اطور
وقف اطلاق
النار حتى الان المبعوث الامومي لم يتم
مقابلته من قبل رئيس الجمهوريه ولا من قبل
الحكومه اليمنيه الحكومه اليمن يعني
المبعوث الامومي لم يكن له موقفا واضحا
اذا ما يتعرض له المواطنين ابرياء في في
مارب ثلاثه اشهر والحوثي مستمر في التحشيد
وفي قتل المدنيين وفي القصف الم المدينه
الاهله بالسكان اكرب ما يقارب 3 مليون
تقصف بالصواريخ البالستيه لم نسمع يعني اي
تصريح ادانه او جهود حقيقيه من قبل
المبعوث الاممي او مجلس الامن بخلاف عندما
في الحديثه تحركوا وكانوا يرفعون شعار
الوضع الانساني لكن ما جرى في مارب لم
نسمع اي خبر ولذلك من السابق الاان ان
نتحدث ان جماعه الحوثي غير جده قلق فيما
يتعلق بمارب كما اعرب عن قلقه فيما يتعلق
بحصار مطار صنعاء لكن تحذيرات المبعوث
الاممي من خطوره الوضع في اليمن تتزامن
كذلك مع اتصالات اجراها وزير الدوله
للشؤون الخارجيه السعودي عادل الجبير مع
نظرائه في عده دول منها الامارات ومصر
والبحرين والكويت واليمن والاردن والسودان
وجيبوتي بل والمغرب وباكستان والسنغال
وماليزيا وغيرها كما بحث نائب وزير
الخارجيه الروسي الوضع في اليمن مع علي
حيدر ممثل قياده المجلس الانتقالي الجنوبي
قالت الخارجيه الروسيه ان الوزير سيرجي
لافروف شدد في اتصال هاتفي مع نظيره
السعودي فيصل بن فرحان على ان تحقيق
السلام والاستقرار في اليمن لا يمكن الا
من خلال مراعاه مصالح جميع القوى السياسيه
والطوائف اليمنيه واضافت الخارجيه الروسيه
في بيان ان لافروف وابن فرحان بحثا دعم
جهود الامم المتحده للتوصل الى وقف لاطلاق
النار واتخاذ تدابير انسانيه عاجله واطلاق
عمليه
سياسيه شامله في اليمن وقالت الوزاره ان
لافروف اشار خلال الاتصال الهاتفي الذي
جرى بمبادره من الجانب السعودي الى
المبادره التي كانت روسيا قد طرحتها
لتطوير مفهوم امني في منطقه
الخليج وعلى ضوء كل هذا نسال هل تؤشر هذه
التحركات والاتصالات الى امكانيه انطلاق
مسار جديد للسلام في اليمن واعود الى ضيفي
من نيويورك عبد الحميد
ما حدود الدور الروسي ماذا يمكن ان تقدم
روسيا في الملف اليمني ما هي
اوراقها بالتاكيد روسيا دوله مهمه وخاصه
انها عضو دائم في مجلس الامن ودائما هناك
مواقف تقريبا متشابهه في مجلس الامن في
الملف اليمني وبالتالي اعتقد ان روسيا
تريد ان ان تتخطى حتى الموقف الجماعي في
مجلس الامن وتتصل بالاطراف ولها علاقات
تاريخيه مع جنوب اليمن ولذلك هذا الاتصال
مع المجلس الانتقالي الجنوبي يعيد ذكريات
علاقات الاتحاد السوفيتي قديما بجنوب
اليمن وانه هناك تفهما للوضع في الجنوب
لانه كان مهملا من يعني ه الاتصال بالمج
الانتقال الجنوبي من جانب الروس هل هو
تفاهم ايراني اماراتي روسي ام هو فقط
تفاهم اماراتي
روسي لا اعتقد انه تقارب الم قف الروسي من
الوضع في اليمن وخاصه تفهم الوضع في
الجنوب لكن لا يعني هذا بالتاكيد تاييد
الانفصال في في الجنوب يعني انا الذي اراه
ان هناك الان جهود جماعيه تاتي من اكثر من
طرف لوقف انزلاق اليمن نحو كارثه حقيقيه
خاصه ان هناك الان كما قال السيد مارتن
جفت والسيد لوكوك ايضا قال ان هناك مجاعه
على الابواب تهدد حوالي سبعه الى 8 ملايين
يمني المساعدات لم تصل
لحيم واريد ان لحظ في اريد ان اضيف بيان
وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه لو تسمح لي ان
نتحدث عن اطار اقليمي عن امن الخليج وكانه
روسيا تريد ان تربط او هل انا اسالك هل هي
تريد ان تربط الحل في اليمن بتفاهم في
المنطقه تكون روسيا طرفا فيه وط بطبيعه
الحال تكون ايران طرفا فيه كذلك
نعم هناك تطور للعلاقات بين روسيا وايران
هذا مهم جدا وخاصه في ضوء الاتفاقيات
الجديده بين دوله الامارات والبحرين مع
اسرائيل
وبالتالي تعزيز الوجود الامريكي ووجود
الاسرائيل الامني في المنطقه وبالتالي
مخاوف ايران ستزداد وممكن ان ان ت ان
تضاعف تدخلها في بعض المناطق مثل اليمن
وبالتالي روسيا تريد ان تقف الى جانب
ايران وان تخفف من مخاوفها لهذه
الاتفاقيات لوجود قواعد اسرائيليه قريبه
جدا منها في دوله مثل الامارات ومثل
البحرين لذلك هي ترى الخليج كل بمنطق واحد
وبرؤية ذلك وهل هذا ما يجري الان من وجهه
نظركم نحن نعتقد انه بالامكان ان يكون
هناك حل يمني داخلي وقد جربت الاطراف
اليمنيه للحوار وخرجت الى حلول لكن نحن ما
نعتقده ان العدوان الذي اعلن من واشنطن
قرار استمراره في واشنطن وقرار توقف هذا
العدوان سيكون من واشنطن وكل هذه الاطراف
التي تتحرك هي ليست صاحبه قرار بالنسبه
للدور الروسي نحن نتمنى ان يكون دورا
ايجابيا ودافعا نح نحو السلام بعيدا عن
التشابكات والتجاذبات الاقليميه والتطورات
الجديده التي نعتقد اننا من خلا نحن نعتقد
بانهم يبحثوا عن موطع قدم ليس الروسي ولكن
اقصد الاماراتي واقصد الامريكي عن موطع
قدم للاسرائيليين منيه ويريد ان يخلط
الاوراق هذه نحن نتعامل معها بانها تطورات
اقليميه تلقي بضلالها على الملف اليمني لا
شك وسنواجهه كجزء من هذا العدوان لكن
توقيف الحرب هو بقرار من واشنطن ويجب ان
يت قف من واشنطن وقرار من واشنطن ولا وليس
لهذه الاطراف الا ان تتلقى الاشاره من قبل
من يحرك هذه الحرب ويديرها لتتحرك في
السلام اما نحن في الطرف الوطني في صنعاء
فقرار يمني وقرارنا ليس في الخارج ونستطيع
ان نتخذ القرار المناسب في اللحظه
المناسبه اذا ما كانت هناك فيه نحو السلام
سنكون كذل طيب انت انتم تقولون دائما انكم
مع وحده اليمن ومع عدم وجود اجانب في
الشان اليمني لكن لقاء بوجدانوف لقاء
الروس بعلي حيدر من المجلس الجنوبي
الانتقالي اليس هذا مصدر قلق وريبه
بالنسبه
لكم الروسي هو يلتقي بالاطراف كلها وليس
هذا ليس اول لقاء من هذا النوع وقد التقوا
من قبل ولكن نحن نتمنى للجميع لن نعادي
العالم كله والروسي ليس له تواجد عسكري في
اليمن واذا كانت هذه اللقاءات في اطار
الدفع نحو عمليه سلام وانهاء هذا العدوان
فهذه خطوه جيده ولا يعني ونحن نرحب بهذه
الخطه اما ان كانت في غير ذلك فحكمها حكم
غيرها محمد قيزان وكيل وزاره الاعلام
اليمنيه من اسطنبول نريد ان نفهم تحركات
وزير الخارجيه السعودي كيف تفهمون انتم
اتصالات وزير الخارجيه السعودي او اتصالات
السعوديه سواء وزير الخارجيه فيصل بن
فرحان او
وكيل وزير الدوله لشؤون الخارجيه عادل
الجبير مع اختراف كثيره في الواقع هل هل
هذا جزء من تحرك ما ما هو هذا التحرك ما
الذي يجري ترتيبه الان
كما ذكرت لك اخي الكريم الحكومه اليمنيه
ما تؤكد مرارا حرصها الكامل على احلال
السلام الشامل واظهرت في الفتره او الاونه
الاخيره المرونه في التجاوب الايجابي مع
الكثير من الدعوات والمبادرات التي تدعو
الى الحل الشامل واحراز تقدم في العمليه
السياسيه في اليمن لكن للاسف الشديد جماعه
الحوثي غير جاده جماعه الحوثي لا تم لك
القرار جماعه الحوثي قرارها في ايران وهي
تحاول الان ان تدغدغ مشاعر الناس من اجل
بس ان تحضر نفسها هي لا تعيش الا على
العمل العسكري الان هي تهاجم في اكثر من
جبهه هي لا تقدم اي مبادرات تدل على انها
تريد السلام حتى الان ما زالت تعتقل
المواطنين اليوم او بالامس اغلقت مطار
صنعاء امام الرحلات الدوليه الانسانيه ما
زالت حتى الان يعني لا تتعاون مع المجتمع
الدولي في اطار خازن خزان صافر في البحر
البحر الاحمر الدي مستمر في اعتقالات
مستمر لس ل رغبه لاي حال اذا كانت اذا
كانت الحاله كهذه فلماذا ذهب وفد حكومه
الحكومه الرئيس هذه الى جنيف للقاء مع
الحوثيين اذا كان ام ان هذا مجرد ذر مجرد
ذر للرماد في
العيون لا الاجتماع الذي سيعقد في في في
جنيف بسويسرا الذي يرعاه مكتب المبعوث
الاممي للامم المتحده واللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر هو يعني للجان الاشراف هو
امتداد للاتفاقات التي تسعى الى اطلاق
مبادله مبادله الاسرى التي كانت في
المرحله الثالثه في الاردن الاطلاق الاسرى
الكل مباد مبادئ مقابل الكل والتي كانت في
المرحله الثالثه في الاردن واتفقوا على
1420 اسير
ومختطات الحوثي للاسف الشديد لم تتعامل
ولم تتفاعل في ذلك حتى الان تخفي
المعلومات عن الاربعه
الرئيسيين الذين شملهم قرار المجلس الامن
وخاصه الاستاذ محمد قحطان الي حتى الان لا
تعرف اسرته اما زال حي ام ميت تمن حتى
الاتصال به جماعه الحوثي حتى الان تحاكم
الاعلاميين واصدرت بحق مجموعه منهم قرارات
بالاعدام ممارسه الحوثي على في الميدان لا
تدل على انها جاده في اتفاق السلام وانما
تدغدغ مشاعر الناس للاستهلاك الاعلامي فقط
استاذ عبد الحميد صيام مريد ان اسال ايضا
عن تحركات السعوديه مع الروس ومع اطراف
عده كيف نفهم هذه
التحركات اذا كانت الحال كهذه كما يقول
ضيفنا من اسطنبول وضيفنا من صنعاء انه لا
يوجد يعني هنالك عدم ثقه بين الطرفين
وربما ذهبوا الى محادثات جنيف لاستطلاع
الامر كيف نفهم التحركات السعوديه اتصالات
الخارجيه السعوديه بكل هذه الاطراف في
الايام
الماضيه
السعوديه وجدت نفسها في ورطه شديده هي
تريد ان تخرج من مازق وضعت نفسها فيه ولا
تعرف كيف المخرج هذه حرب مكلفه ولا يوجد
اي افق للانتصار عسكريا على الاطلاق حتى
تحالفها مع الامارات لم يعد قويا الامارات
طردوا جنود الحكومه الشرعيه المدعومه من
السعوديه من جزيره سقطره واقاموا تقريبا
حكما ذاتيا تماما في الجنوب بدون لموافقه
السعوديه واتفاقيه الرياض التي عقدت في
نوفمبر
2019 لم يحترمها الاماراتيين على الاطلاق
لذلك وجدت ان طريق الطريق الى ايران تمر
من روسيا وبالتالي اذا استطاعت ان تتوصل
الى تفاهم مع روسيا وروسيا تتوصل الى
تفاهم مع ايران ممكن ان يكون هناك مخرج
لهذه الازمه التي وجدت نفسها السعوديه
فيها تصور ان السعوديه لم ت يقدم الى الان
لا هي ولا الامارات فلسا واحدا للاموال
التي تعهدوا بدفعها لصندوق المساعدات
اليمنيه تصور ان الان السعوديه لا تجد اي
مدافع عنها عن مواقفها وخاصه في
موضوع المدنيين وقتل الاطفال واستهداف
المدنيين والمدارس والمستشفيات لذلك
وانتقادات يبدو ان هنالك مشكله في الصوت
معك استاذ عبد الحميد صيام ربما نعود اليك
لاحقا لكن نصر الدين عامر من
صنعاء هل هذه رؤيته يعني اذا كان ما يقول
الاستاذ عبد الحميد صحيحا فهذا يعني ان
ربما التسويه تصاغ بعيدا عنكم ايضا ربما
تصغ في موسكو والرياض
وطهران اي حلول تاتي من الخارج وليس للشان
اليمني ليس لنا فيها علاقه لا يمكن ولا لا
يمكن ان تكون لها اثر في الميدان قرارنا
في صنعاء دائما ما يعني ما ياتي مثلا
المبعوث الاممي لنقاش القضيه اليمنيه معنا
في صنعاء ولا يذهب لنقاش في الرياض كل هذا
هو كلام مكرر واسطوانه ليست حقيقيه يعني
تكرر دائما الحديث عن ايران وايران في
الملف اليمني هو كلام مكرر ولا يمكن ان
يقدم ان يؤخر الحل هو كما ذكرت لك في
البدايه بقرار من واشنطن مثل ما اعلن
العدوان من واشنطن سيكون الر من واشنطن
اما بالنسبه لنا وماذا بايدينا نحن
بايدينا الميدان العسكري وكلما تقدمت
القوات اليمنيه المسلحه في مختلف المناطق
المحتله لتحريرها تكون فرص السلام اكثر
ويكون الحديث عالميا عن السلام اكثر اليوم
هناك تقدمات عسكريه اكبر نفس الوقت نسمع
الحديث كثير عن السلام اي ان هذا المسار
هو ما يعزز السلام ويعزز فرص السلام ويدفع
باتجاه السلام وكذلك باتجاه رفع الحصار
الذي يخنك الشعب اليمني السيد محمد خيزان
كيف تفهمون تصريح ايضا مارتن جريفث عن
الاستعانه بالمجتمع المدني واعطاء دور
اكبر للمجتمع المدني في التسويه القادمه
وتحدث عن النساء وعن فئات مختلفه وعن يعني
يمن يعيش فيه الجميع بشكل متوازن هل هذا
هو الحل السياسي المنتظر هل هل تم اطلاعكم
على ما ينوي السيد جريفث فعله بهذا
الشان
الحكومه اليمنيه ترحب باي جهود سواء كان
للاشقاء او الاصدقاء لاحلال السلام والضغط
على جماعه الحوثي لوقف اعتداءاتها على
الشعب اليمني وعلى المدنيين السيد غريفيث
و من خلال يعني جهوده او لقاءاته نحن نرى
انها لم ترقى الى المستوى الى المستوى
المطلوب وانما كما يقول الشارع انها ليست
الا يعني وسيله لاستمرار عمل المبعوث
وفريق عمله لكن حتى الان ليست جهود حقيق
لوقف اعتداءات جماما جماعه الحوثي جماعه
الحوثي حتى الان يعني خسرت الان الكثير من
مقاتليها دخلت في حرب حرب الصحراء في الجو
في مارب بالمئات يعني وصلت الى الالاف
خلال الثلاث الاشهر اتوقع انهم يريدون
الان من خلال اتفاقيه الاسرى ان ان يحرروا
بعض مقاتليه ليدفعوا بهم الجبهات الخاويه
حتى
الانما تبحث الان عن اي انقاذ لها وعن
هدنه حتى تستعيد انفها
لماذا تتجاوب مع اذا كان هذا هو مقصدهم
لماذا تتجاوب معهم في
ذلك نحن نرحب نحن نرحب بالسلام ونحن
نستشعر معاناه شعبنا وخاصه المحافظات التي
ترزح
تحت المليشيات والحياه الصعبه التي
يعيشونها انعدام الخدمات توقف المرتبات
اجبارهم واخذ الاطفال الى الجب هات هذه
المعاناه يعني تؤرق الحكومه اليمنيه كان
هناك اتفاق عبر المبعوث الاممي على صرف
مرتبات في المناطق التي تخضع للحوثي لكن
جماعه الحوثي للاسف الشديد صدرت ما يقارب
50 مليار من الحساب الخاص محمد قيزان وكيل
وزاره الاعلام اليمنيه من اسطنبول اشكرك
شكرا جزيلا لاننا وصلنا لنهايه الحلقه
اشكر ايضا نصر الدين عامر وكيل وزاره
الاعلام التابع للحوثين من صنعاء واشكر
ضيفي من نيويورك عبد الحميد صيام الخبير
في شؤون الامم متحده نهايه هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في
قراءه جديده لما وراء خبر جديد حتى ذلكم
الحين في رعايه الله وامنه السلام
[موسيقى]
عليكم